mehr Kohle verfeuern Atome
energiestrecken und Rabatt auf Benzin
und Diesel viele grüne denken gerade
sind wir eigentlich noch grün genug
gerade nach diesem Sommer fürchten viele
noch mehr die Drohne Klimakatastrophe
gerade vor diesem Winter fürchten sich
aber auch viele vor der nächsten
Gasrechnung versteigenden Preisen und
vor dem sozialen Abstieg keine Partei
zerreißt das mehr als die Grünen und
keiner Partei drohen jetzt so starke
Brüche wie den Grünen wo genau das
zeigen wir euch bei instad politics
um die schwierige Lage der Grünen heute
zu verstehen müssen wir noch mal ganz
kurz gucken wo die eigentlich herkommen
bei uns im Archiv findet man sie die Uhr
grün vielfältig sehr viel Bart und alle
Strecken ständig und natürlich
Protestsongs
[Musik]
nicht länger mit mal kurz vorgespult zum
Vergleich heute viel weniger Bart und
viel viel mehr Krawatte früher
jedenfalls waren die Grünen noch
anti-parteienpartei absolut gegen Krieg
absolut gegen Atomkraft für mehr
Umverteilung für mehr Ökologie und ohne
Bock auf Kompromisse aber diese grünen
gibt's gar nicht mehr ein ganz berühmter
verwandlungsmoment in der Partei
Geschichte ist der hier 1999 Joschka
Fischer ist grüner Außenminister und
wird auf dem eigenen Parteitag beworfen
und ausgepfiffen weil er dafür ist
deutsche Soldaten in den Kosovo zu
schicken er setzt sich zum Schluss aber
durch und macht die Grünen zu einer
anderen Partei und das ist der Punkt wo
Bündnis 90 die Grünen nicht mehr
Protestpartei sind danach war es das so
ziemlich mit der Protestpartei dann
waren die Grünen vor allem linke
projektpartei also wenn regieren dann
auf jeden Fall nur mit SPD und später
auch mit den Linken aber auch das ist
vorbei die jüngste Verwandlung der
Grünen findet ganz ohne
farbbeutel-attacken und auspfeifen statt
genau 20 Jahre nach dem fischerparteitag
da kommt ganz leise ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm verfasst von wem
bärburg und Habeck dass wir glauben wir
stehen mal am Spielfeld dran lassen die
anderen laufen und rufen mal dazu ein
bisschen schneller das ist vorbei wir
wollen selber Spielführer sein und in
die Mitte vom Spiel und ab jetzt nennen
sich die Grünen bündnispartei offen für
die Linkspartei aber eben auch offen für
die CDU und vor allem offen für die
macht da waren die Grünen wirklich
überreif und wollten endlich mitregieren
und schon da hat etwas starke litten was
ich jetzt zu einem richtigen Problem
auswachsen könnte da haben die Grünen
auf Parteitagen nur noch wenig gepfiffen
und gestritten und dafür viel viel
geklatscht
entgegen des eigenen Klischees von
früher hat sich die Partei heftige
Auseinandersetzung ja irgendwie
abgewöhnt und es stattdessen ziemlich
Macht bewusst geworden seit habe und
bärburg Parteivorsitzende waren haben
bei den Grünen die Pragmatiker das sagen
also praktisch der rechte Flügel der
Partei das gilt jetzt auch für die
Grünen der Ampel die Vertreter des
linken Flügels den es stärker ums
unbedingt in grün sein geht werden
entweder abserviert sowie Anton
Hofreiter der wollte Verkehrsminister
werden durfte aber nicht oder die müssen
ausgewechselt werden so wie die
Familienministerin Anne Spiegel
interessant ist das große Teile der
Basis und auch der Bundestagsfraktion
aber eigentlich links ticken die halten
sich mit Kritik nur zurück so und das
hat mehrere Gründe erstens in den Zeiten
des Ukraine Krieges wollen die nicht
Unruhe stiften und nörgeln zweitens sie
wollen den ampelpartner FDP nicht
provozieren die haben nämlich zuletzt
schmerzhaft Landtagswahlen verloren
eigentlich alle in diesem Jahr und haben
jetzt auch Angst vor Niedersachsen der
und gucken jetzt wo sie bleiben und
drittens es läuft ja die Umfragen sind
gut und bis vor kurzem sah es ja noch so
aus als ob Robert Habeck sich schon mal
im Kanzleramt umgucken könnte in
Hintergrundgesprächen aber kommt bei
vielen der Frust hoch eigentlich wollen
die nämlich dringend dass die Grünen mal
wieder grüner werden mal zeigen wo die
Grenze ist und auch mal auf den Tisch
hauen
da gibt es einen deutlichen Widerwillen
Überzeugungen aufzugeben oder anzupassen
auch wenn die Realität vielleicht jetzt
anders ist und es nötig macht tja da
wollen viele eben doch weniger
bündnispartei sein und mehr
Protestpartei wie früher so und bei
keinem anderen Thema zeigt sich das so
wie beim streckbetrieb für
Atomkraftwerke da ist die Partei noch so
wie sie früher war und wie sie sich
selbst eigentlich heute noch gerne sieht
das ist so eine rote Linie ihr wisst
schon atomkraft nein danke Robert Habeck
hat deshalb versucht seiner Partei da
nicht wehzutun gleichzeitig musste aber
das Problem lösen aber explan
Atomkraftwerke sollen eben doch nicht
länger laufen und nur im äußersten
Notfall hochgefahren werden als
sogenannte Reserve laut Experten aber
ist genau das wie schlechteste aller
Lösung weil man dann eben die Kosten hat
die Atomkraftwerke weiter zu betreiben
aber liefern keinen Strom wenn es nach
Christian Lindner geht dem FDP-Chef dann
könnten Atomkraftwerke auch noch
deutlich länger laufen und er sieht
dafür auch noch Chancen wir haben in der
Bundesregierung dazu bislang keine
abschließende Entscheidung getroffen das
ist noch zu besprechen Christian Lindner
irrt das letzte Wort ist im Zweifel
gesprochen da steht im Koalitionsvertrag
unterschrieben von Christian Lindner der
Betrieb von Atomkraftwerken endet am
Jahresende ihr seht die atomkraftdebatte
die ist noch längst nicht abgeräumt
interessant ist auch das atomkraft nein
danke für die älteren grünen zwar
wirklich das über Thema der Partei ist
andere das aber mittlerweile gar nicht
mehr ganz so eng sehen ja und die Grünen
Finnland die wundern sich sogar über die
Schwesterpartei in Deutschland für die
es Atomstrom nämlich nicht das Problem
sondern Teil der Lösung wenn es darum
geht klimaneutral zu werden ja und auch
viele junge grüne in Deutschland haben
ein größeres Problem damit dass der
grüne Wirtschaftsminister jetzt
Kohlekraftwerke hochfahren lässt und
damit der CO2-Ausstoß steigt ja und da
sind wir bei der Bruchstelle der Grünen
mitregieren bedeutet für sie gerade
ständiges abwägen Kompromisse schließen
und zurückstecken im eigentlichen
Kernthema und das beißt sich sehr stark
mit den Erwartungen die die Grünen mal
geweckt haben im Wahlkampf hat die
Partei maximal Alarm geschlagen diese
Regierung jetzt sei die letzte die noch
Einfluss auf die Klimakrise nehmen kann
ihre Stimme entscheidet über die letzte
Regierung die aktiv Einfluss auf die
Klimakrise nehmen kann ja und umso
schmerzhafter ist jetzt das Regieren
wenn fossile Brennstoffe länger genutzt
werden und die Klimaziele immer weiter
in die Ferne rücken eben diese Lücke
zwischen grünen Erwartungen und der
Realität mit kriselner Wirtschaft und
krassen Energieproblemen die wird immer
größer und damit zu einem immer größeren
Problem für die Grünen die eigentlich
grünen nahe Fridays for future Bewegung
jedenfalls lässt ihre Enttäuschung
freien Lauf ja insbesondere die Grünen
und damit auch die Ministerin Steffi
Lemke und Robert Habeck schreiben sicher
den Kampf gegen die Krise den Kampf
gegen das atemsterben unfassbar hoch auf
die Fahne und gleichzeitig sehen wir
dass die Politik die gerade von ihnen
betrieben wird diese Probleme weiter
verschärft ja und da ist schwierig für
die Partei das Ifo-Institut hat
ausgerechnet 7 Prozent der
Stimmengewinne für die Grünen gehen
direkt auf diese schülerproteste zurück
das ist also ein wichtiger Stimmanteil
für die Partei tja und auch
Umweltverbände können sich nicht so
richtig anfreunden mit den
regierungsgrünen also ist das noch grün
bei den Grünen entscheidet sich gerade
wie sie in den nächsten Jahren
wahrgenommen werden schauen sie eher auf
die Machbarkeit oder auf den Markenkern
funktioniert das wirklich mit dem
Konzept der bündnispartei oder ist Ihnen
die FDP dann doch vielleicht ein
bisschen zu wesensfremd so oder so sie
müssen es der Basis dann irgendwann
sagen tja und dann hoffen dass die da
nicht kommen mit wir haben jetzt die
Schnauze voll es ist genug ihr treibt zu
kommen was meint ihr wollt ihr lieber
richtig grüne grüne oder ist blass grüne
okay wenn man dafür mit regieren und
mitentscheiden kann diskutiert gerne mit
in den Kommentaren und abonniert wenn
ihr wollt gerne auch unseren ZDF heute
Kanal da findet ihr regelmäßig neue
Folgen von uns von insert politic